[Musique]
les forces martiniquaises de progrès
veulent d'une dynamique de sursaut et
d'une mobilisation bonjour miguel
laventure bonjour à tous les auditeurs
et bonjour à martinez première le
secrétaire général des forces
martiniquaises de progrès qui se sont
réunis au cours du week-end à
rivière-salée dynamique de sur son
immobilisation oui mais avec qui la
question du renouvellement des troupes a
quand même été soulevée dimanche pire
que l'argent il ya quand même les bras
et les têtes pour mener tout combat
miguel laventure alors c'est vrai qu' il
n'y a pas de mouvements de parti
d'action politique 100 personnes 100
individus sans femmes et hommes et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je veux saluer
et féliciter en tout cas remercier
beaucoup toutes celles et ceux qui lient
à 20 ans ont pris le pari de faire en
sorte qu'il existe une expression
martiniquaise différentes de toute
l'offre politique qui existait donc en
1998 remercier des survivants miguel
laventure je remercie des combattants
des militants des personnes qui ont
considéré que la martinique justifiait
l'engagement politique vous savez on dit
beaucoup que le sens de l'engagement du
militantisme du bénévolat on le voit par
exemple dans la vie associative le sens
de l'autre disparaît s'émousse et bien
quand vous avez des personnes qui
décident de faire en sorte que leurs
intérêts soient secondaire par rapport à
celui de la martinique qui c'est un
élément essentiel des forces
martiniquaises de progrès fondamental
eh bien il faut leur tirer un coup de
chapeau et il faut le donner en exemple
ou que d'autres viennent y ajouter la
dynamique pour nous c'est précisément de
maintenir ce flux de faire un sens bien
je dirais génération continue et
s'appuyer sur ce socle de valeurs celles
de la droite
j'aimerais vraiment ce matin vous
entendre sur votre définition de la
doite ici en martinique en février 2018
miguel laventure être deux doigts de ça
veut dire quoi
alors si vous savez il y avait une
définition uniforme mais dur est
d'ailleurs un seul organisme qui
mettrait sous son panneau droite
et puis les tout le monde se
rassembleraient derrière et il y aurait
probablement à ce moment là
je dirais une forme de rigidité
peut-être d'uniformité un peu mortelle
mais franchement cela dit la droite
courageuse je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous
ne nous définissons pas prioritairement
comme étant de droite il nous
définissons prioritairement comme étant
la ville dit tout à l'heure
comme étant un mouvement profondément
ancrée sur la martinique avec un certain
nombre de valeurs savez c'est pas par
hasard que le terme a été retenu de
forces martiniquaises au pluriel d'un
progrès et à l'époque je vous disais
vous aurait même pu ajouter
révolutionnaire on aurait voulu avoir
dix ans dans ce cas effectivement on
était un peu en contre point par rapport
à ce qui existait et ça a été d'ailleurs
vécu comme tel par certaines personnes
qui s'inquiétait de notre arrivée et
nous avons montré à la martinique que
l'on pouvait avoir quelques références
fondamentales le sens de la
responsabilité ne pas dire prétendre
proposer n'importe quoi les autres
formations politiques disent exactement
la même chose beagle à votre sur les
toits et aujourd'hui en martinique sé
quissac
mais non mais comment voulez vous que je
me définissent comme exclusivement de
droite jusque vous voulez mener des
combats voulait une dynamique de sursaut
volet d'une mobilisation mais autour de
qui ça nous avons trop d'heures
laissez moi vous dire les valeurs d
ancien ce mois la responsabilité je vous
le disais mais je pense que vous avez
compris cela la solidarité le respect
des personnes des personnes là la
référence aux personnes je redis que
c'est pour nous quelque chose
d'essentiel peut-être d'ailleurs que
c'est un des points que l'on retrouve
chez ya ceux qui se revendiquent de
cette grande famille de droite ou du
centre droit mais aussi le la notion de
l'engagement et de la démocratie
chez nous c'est absolument quelque chose
de fondamental je dis pas que l'état
n'existe pas ailleurs
ce que je dis c'est que probablement
nous mettons tout cela en priorité un
peu supérieurs franchement que ce que je
peux voir dans d'autres organisations
que je ne veux pas critiquer parce
qu'elles vont le droit parce que ce que
vous dénoncez là c'est ce qu'on retrouve
dans certaines coalition comme celle du
grand ensemble et pumba pire chose
lorsqu'on entend tout ce qui se passe en
ce moment notre nouveau centre si vous
voulez m'emmener dans les querelles des
autres d'aller bien comprendre que je
vais pas vous suivre
et vous orienter que dimanche nous avons
dit ni querelle ni corps ni ni ingérence
dans les organismes des autres nous
avons à tenir notre cap et faire en
sorte que nous puissions répondre aux
attentes d'un public d'une population
d'un nombre d'hommes et de femmes de
martinique qui aujourd'hui considèrent
que nous sommes une opportunité nous
sommes un chemin nous sommes une
perspective
vous n'êtes pas noyer n'est pas perdu
votre âme votre identité
lorsqu'en décembre 2015 vous êtes
retrouvé par quand surprise générale
dans cette condition qui aujourd'hui
mène cette collectivité territoriale de
martinique alors je pense que
aujourd'hui c'est un combat c'est pas
dans un débat qui est dépassé
très clairement chacun a vu qu' on ne
sait absolument diluée dans rien du tout
on a peur que ça fait deux ans que vous
avez gardé votre femme votre esprit et
cette assemblée générale le dimanche est
pas déjà pour se positionner par rapport
à 2021 qui arrivera très vite mégane
l'aventuré nous ne sommes pas dans cette
espèce de comédiens d'excitation ou
d'opposition de la prochaine échéance
une touche de l'état trois ans nous
sommes plutôt dans la nécessité d'avoir
la combinaison du réel du concret et de
l'immédiat et en même temps de la vision
ce qui est très important pour nous ce
n'est pas l'échéance à venir c'est où
allons nous que faisons nous et comment
faisons-nous ou lamartine très bien très
bien miguel laventure osé poser les
questions dites nous quel est votre état
des lieux aujourd'hui en février 2018 je
le rappelle écoutez fondamentalement
nous allons le répéter jusqu'à ce que
nous soyons parvenus à inverser la
tendance fondamentalement il faut que
nous mesurions le désastre que constitue
cette dépression démographique ce recul
démographique ce départ de nos jeunes
qui vont ailleurs chercher la seule
chose qu'il leur manque en martinique
pour y rester c'est à dire le job
les martiniquais et les martiniquais
aujourd'hui leur nombre diminue depuis
une dizaine d'années c'est effarant et
je suis encore très surpris de voir que
la prise de conscience est trop lente
sur ce sujet il nous faut par conséquent
faire en sorte que nous puissions
réussir surtout les les dans tous les
domaines dans tout l'est dans tous les
secteurs il faut
nous puissions avoir comme objectif
écoutez bien la martinique au top la
martinique qui rayonne la martinique qui
gagne la martinique au top
si nous arrivons à faire ça à nos jeunes
vont rester vous savez c'est quand même
assez assez effarant et et douloureux
pour toutes les familles mais aussi pour
la martinique global de la voiture de
voir que il y a tant de compétences de
temps de capacités tant de tant de
talents dans sa vie depuis que vous êtes
dans cette coalition qui gouverne en
martinique avec la septième notamment on
le disait déjà auparavant
et cette dynamique et de sursaut serait
donc tout simplement faire en sorte
qu'on prenne conscience de cette de
cette démocratie et de démographie qui
berce en martinique si on entend la
science ont goûté tu attends beaucoup
pensaient déjà femme attendait si on en
prend conscience on agit nous avons
utilisé cette formule dimanche que je
reprends que nous devons faire des
difficultés que nous rencontrons des
opportunités est ensuite transformé ces
opportunités en opérationnalité ça veut
dire quoi
il y avait auparavant monté pas si vous
voulez vraiment savoir
et regardez moi je pose des questions
parce qu'il y avait clairement
aujourd'hui des domaines dans lesquels
nous avons besoin par exemple les
risques majeurs les risques sous
lesquels nous nous exposons à faire en
sorte que la martinique soit une
véritable terre d' expertise nous avons
ce terrible fléau de nos terres qui ont
été pourri empoisonné par la chlordécone
il faut faire en sorte que puissent être
en martinique base et des dispositifs de
remise en état de mobilisation des
dispositifs scientifique il faut faire
de la martinique le pôle d'excellence en
la matière il faut faire en sorte qu' on
en parle beaucoup mais tout ce qui
concerne la question des énergies
puissent véritablement s'organiser et
c'est sur ça que nous avons à travailler
si vous vous que nous parlons de la ctm
on peut le faire mais vous avez proposé
qu'on soit du fmp
oui mais je n'ai lu des forces
martiniquaises de progrès comment faire
en sorte que ce ne restent pas que de
simples bouts
ben là vous êtes aux commandes aurait
précisé qu est ce qui est fait pour que
les martiniquais se rendent compte qu'il
ya quelque chose qui se passe qui se
fait alors se construit je vais vous
prendre quelques exemples qui sont un
petit peu je dirais plus proche de demi
d'intervention
vous savez que je suis en charge en
particulier des fonds européens
et bien aujourd'hui aujourd'hui moi je
vous le dis très clairement la ctm a
pris le choix a fait le choix de faire
en sorte que ces fonds européens fléché
comme ils sont soit utilisé avec une
intensité qui très clairement va faire
en sorte que nous puissions donner à la
martinique
cette opérationnalité cette
transformation de ce que des
opportunités existent mais que nous
avons les transformer en réalité faire
en sorte que nous puissions avoir un bon
avant la martinique au top c'est pas une
chose qui est une image et ses doigts
sont plus qu'un slogan
beauxis que ce lot dont beaucoup plus
que ça c'est un engagement et c'est
là-dessus d'ailleurs ça a été la
conclusion de notre réunion dimanche des
groupes ont été constitués et vous allez
voir que pendant toute cette année de
nos 20 ans nous allons énoncer des
propositions qui bien entendu trouver
leur place dans les réalisations de la
ctm les forces martiniquaises de progrès
pas seulement un mouvement un vrai parti
politique un vrai parti politique qui
s'engagent et qui continue merci d'avoir
été ce matin avec nos billets de l'
aventure secrétaire général des fn des
fmp fausse note ni caisse de poudre est
bonne aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup